[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenas tardes suena
y nombres de alejandro de los que tengo
47 años
hace más 25 que trabajo en los medios de
comunicación argentinos especialmente
medios gráficos en los escritos diarios
revistas y desde hace más de
10 van a ser 14 el año que viene son
muchos años soy profesor en la
universidad buenos aires dictó la
materia el taller 3
facultades ya sociales
una estaba invitado un programa
televisión fuimos una tanda en el corte
se acerca otros invitados y me dice
ahora cuando vimos al aire
te pondré un vaso de agua en la cara
wow
e
sí bueno no se vieron cuando cuando se
les ocurre la respuesta perfecta pero 20
minutos después que sí
bueno a mí es a veces me ocurrió el
momento que hagamos lo que tengo que
hacer el tipo me dice nuevamente es que
decir algo agresivo algo insultante o me
hace el pie
tiene un vaso en la cara bueno esto lo
hacemos volvemos y esto fue lo que pasó
como artista
con torpe de una donante está
modestísimo noticia tirando mediocre
ha conseguido por favor vuelve a
cantarlo en el fin terminó el programa
salimos todo el aire eso es hasta detrás
de cámara
tiene un abrazo
salió genial
no salgamos juntos a la puerta ahora al
canal de canal porque a lo mejor hay
prensa mente y se va a caer
no estás hablando el patrón calor
se va a quedar mentira la que me acaba
de armar y al día siguiente yo lo llamo
al día siguiente oa los días hay poquito
y luego ya flaco
yo voy a contar lo que pasó va a salir
una columna ahora esto lo tenemos
ya
la mañana va a salir una columna donde
yo voy a contar la verdad donde yo voy a
contar que viniste
me dijiste en un corte que me hace me
pediste permiso para temas a buena cara
me lo tiras
yo voy a contar la verdad porque sé que
yo no soy mediático
yo soy periodista flaco vivo
entonces que avisa no traiciona sabes
que me contestó
genial así lo niego
no hacia distintos
yo estoy acá voy
por qué
mismo hablarles
de la verdad
la verdad
o mejor dicho
de su crisis
la verdad como categoría
traficadas
transmisible
por el enunciado periodístico la verdad
que nos cuentan los medios de esa verdad
le vengo a hablar de la crisis de esa
verdad de vengo a hablar les vengo a
decir los invito a pensar a preguntarnos
si tal vez esa verdad
no se ha muerto
porque todas risas hasta que deja de
serlo
saben que están haciendo los medios con
la verdad
y la canción
[Aplausos]
levantan
a la verdad
otro ejemplo el año pasado en mi cierre
de la cruzada en sociales invité a
victoria xipolitakis a una clase al
final no con para cerrar el año la iii
de la fórmula una entrevista grupal
donde los chicos pudieran preguntar las
cosas que nos contar un poco la cocina
de los medios masivos de comunicación
yo quería
expiar un poco yo y mis alumnos queremos
orejear ahí ver qué pasa en los
backstage en donde se arma lo que
después será enunciado público
los me dijeron esto
que vi que era una profesora
que había dado una insólita clase
ustedes ven que son medios masivos no
son esto no es una radio del barrio
no morir
ustedes que son medio grande
este que lo conocemos todos los alumnos
de comunicación atentos a las enseñanzas
de la profe dio cátedra
este soy yo
con el doctor que conduce acá de la
nochecita
es un canal es el canal más visto en un
punto si es el más visto es el que más
confianza ofrece
xipolitakis dio cátedra
está loco
lo que lo que pasó interesante fue que
yo formo la universidad yo como docente
formamos
jóvenes periodistas
que van a contar las noticias
una vez que nosotros fuimos
esta vez los contados
los narrados
y desde el estómago de esa narración
siendo nosotros la noticia
pudiendo vernos nosotros mismos
a mis alumnos siendo contados por los
medios
asistimos pudimos comprobar
la mentira la desinformación
la falacia que los grandes medios de
comunicación en este país y en otros
pero yo vivo acá
mis hijos viven acá mi familia vive acá
a mí me importa acá todo bien allá pero
acá me importa bien y acá los medios que
yo leo
no crearle un título
no importa ni que me dio ni qué país
pero lo que decía los docentes
argentinos rechazan la novena propuesta
salarial del gobierno y la verdad la
verdad
lo que no decía este medio es que entre
la primera y la novena casi no había
habido diferencia
y la primera propuesta salarial y la
novena eran prácticamente la misma
no es mal eso hice luego con los
docentes
no hay tiza que le venga bien
ese título no está informando ese título
está operando ese título no me informa
ese título me opera un pequeño ejercicio
france esta pregunta avance por favor
cada uno de ustedes en cada una de las
butacas que están ocupando ahora avance
por favor esta portavoz está mirando
para otro lado
acepte esta pregunta hace 32 postal
que estoy leyendo para informarme
no hace falta que la donde para ustedes
que estoy leyendo para informar
a quien le estoy creyendo
a quien le estoy comprando la verdad
quién se lleva mi fe del lector
no sienten
por momentos ahí como como en el fondo
de ustedes mismos
cuando están delante de una noticia de
una información
de un paquete de datos de tráfico
público cuando están delante de los
medios no sienten
un poquito los están operando
pueden hacerse con las cabezas o no
no importa que no estoy diciendo cuál es
siempre siempre un poquito de las tan
bonitas
es la verdad
no sienten como una costilla de malestar
cuando se informan no les pasa no les
pasa que esa costilla que además grande
no están hartos
están cansados de que esto pase
[Aplausos]
la verdad
le pones una onda que tragan
muy bien sin líder
qué cosa es un periodista
o qué cosa debería ser un periódico
al escuchar la definición a esteban
smith un tipo al que siempre admiré de
los textos
más allá de nuestras diferencias lo que
pienses un tipo muy claro para para la
metáfora
y así esteban
un periodista es el indio que va hasta
la tribu de al lado
se fije en que andan
vuelve y se lo cuenta a la tribu propia
ahora este indio
en términos ideales por lo menos
no cuenta lo que a él le conviene contar
cuenta lo que su tribu necesita saber
le convenga a él o no le convenga
este indio es el medio
y porque es el medio porque media
y que media la verdad
y qué verdad media el indio este la
verdad de la información
y la verdad de la información organiza
la vida en sociedad
porque todos nos levantamos la mañana y
necesitamos saber si funciona en la
línea b
qué temperatura hace cómo salió el
partido anoche que dijo el presidente
la verdad de los medios es una verdad
crucial crucial para la vida en sociedad
y esa verdad está en crisis
y esa verdad está muerta
cuando el indio vuelve y cuenta le
creemos porque ese indio trabaja de que
le creamos
su actividad medular está hecha de
convocar la fe pública
entre ese indio y nosotros
algo se rompió
hizo crack
eso que se rompió tiene un nombre
confianza
se nos rompió la confianza cuando
asistimos al tráfico de la información
cuando asistimos al tráfico de la verdad
es ya entre la verdad eso que el indio
atestiguó del cuerpo presente
y el relato de la verdad es decir lo que
el indio cuenta siempre hay una
distancia
es lo que separa al hecho del relato del
hecho estamos
cómo se resuelve esa instancia
no se resuelve
qué podemos esperar entonces podemos
esperar y debemos exigir
un compromiso real de parte de este
indio es decir de parte de los medios de
comunicación
en que van a comprometerse con achicar
esa distancia todo lo que puedan
con suprimir la incluso aunque sepan de
antemano que van a fracasar en suprimir
la del todo no es lo que está pasando
no lo está pasando loco
estamos lejos que se esté pasando por
eso es grave
lo que está pasando es que pones a
hendija la que se produce entre el hecho
y su relato
por eso el intersticio que se abre entre
la verdad y la narración periodística de
la verdad
se está formando un interés
que no es el interés por contar la
verdad en los hechos
los medios dejaron de contar lo que la
tribu tiene derecho a saber
para empezar a contar lo que ellos
necesitan que la tribu sepa
y trágico
para morder más mercado
para tener más capacidad de lobby
para operar con más fuerza en el centro
nervioso del sistema representación
política
para obtener más poder
para negociar mejor
[Aplausos]
la verdad
juro que es
desalentador yo tenía 16 años cuando
supe que quería ser periodista
año 87 y cuarto año
mi viejo hermanito se elogie
arrancó muy pobre a los nueve años en mi
huérfano vendiendo frutas en un carro
ahí sobre la calle de san lorenzo una
dehesa mendoza en el centro rosario
de golpe tenía un hijo adolescente que
no iba a seguir sus pasos que no iba a
heredar su obra su trabajo
con 16 años estaba ahí en el auto de mi
viejo
el 505 de los 80 me pasó
y es muerto de miedo yo
porque aparte vieron que la charla entre
un auto es como compartir ascensor con
un vecino que no
y te quedan dos en cápsula queda yo
sentía esa inminencia del costado mi
padre allí en el volante jhon el
copiloto los dos mirando ese parabrisas
entonces lo solté
muerto de miedo dije va
quiero ser periodista
sigo queriendo ser periodista
mi hijo hizo un silencio
qué es lo peor que te pueden hacer
porque puedes y larga algo puteada - e
no no silencio hasta que
dijo
ya que para eso vas a tener mucho y soy
super y me quería y me apoyaba
y que a mí me esperaba una vida dentro
del periodismo argentino 47 años después
estoy acá ayer cerró una nota 2
y yo si no cierra nada la goma
hoy a los 47 asisto a estos enunciados
globales seis grupos verdad
el domingo
son nombre de mentir y cotillón
académico para nombrar el mismo viejo
problema que vamos a contar a quien si
lo vamos a contar y cómo nos vamos a
hacer creer
para mi ojo para mí el priísmo nunca
morirá
porque se trata de un bien social
tal vez le pasa como a las personas que
a tanto necesitan romperse
para renacer morir para nacer de vuelta
es una época difícil para nosotros los
periodistas
la verdad navega en aguas oscuras
inciertas
tal vez el beneficio colateral sea que
produzca
lectores más agudos que nos haga más
exigentes
que nos pongamos que nos enojemos y
exijamos
nuevos y mejores periodistas más y mejor
periodismo
ojalá de verdad ojalá muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y